This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I fell in love with architecture in Chicago, a city known for its pioneering stunning skyscrapers. Every good thing you hear about Chicago architecture is true, and whenever anyone I know takes a trip to Chicago, I tell them the one thing that you have to do is go on the Chicago Architecture Foundation Center boat tour. From the river, you can take in all these amazing buildings while a whipsmart passionate gocent tells you story after story of grand ambitions and visionary architects. But it's important to note that only a small percentage
这里是 99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我爱上了芝加哥的建筑，这是一座以其开创性、令人惊叹的摩天大楼而闻名的城市。你听到的关于芝加哥建筑的所有好话都是真的，每当我认识的人去芝加哥旅行时，我都会告诉他们，你必须做的一件事就是去参加芝加哥建筑基金会中心乘船游览。从河上，你可以欣赏所有这些令人惊叹的建筑，同时一位聪明、热情的导游会给你讲述一个又一个关于宏伟抱负和富有远见的建筑师的故事。但需要注意的是，只有一小部分
of structures are designed by architects. And while an iconic building along the skyline might be the best way to identify a city at a distance, up close, it's the subtle cues and vernacular design that make the city what it is. If someone were to blindfold me, spin me around, and drop me in one of Chicago's 1900 miles worth of alleyways, I would know what city I was in instantly. Not because I could see the Sears Tower, but because from almost any alley, you can see these hefty, robust wooden fire escapes climbing up the backs of two, three, and four-story brick apartment buildings.
建筑物是由建筑师设计的。虽然天际线标志性的建筑可能是远距离识别城市最好的方式，但在近处，正是那些微妙的线索和地方风格设计让这座城市成为现在的样子。如果有人蒙住我的眼睛，把我转个圈，然后把我扔进芝加哥长达 1900 英里的某条小巷里，我马上就会知道我在哪个城市。不是因为我能看到西尔斯大楼，而是因为从几乎任何一条小巷里，你都能看到这些厚实、坚固的木制消防逃生梯，沿着两层、三层和四层砖砌公寓楼的背面向上延伸。
To call it a fire scape is almost a misnomer. They usually have a substantial landing on each floor, so they serve as a de facto porch. A place to store things and hang out with a few friends, grittle up some stakes, and meet the neighbors down in the alley below. These wooden steps and porches started popping up in the early 1900s, bolted onto buildings as a means of emergency escape, because of Chicago's very justified fear of fire. They were utilitarian affairs that became so much more. It seemed to say that the vast majority of these were not designed by architects, and one of the back of my apartment building in Logan Square was so structurally unsound,
叫它消防逃生梯几乎是一个误称。它们通常在每层楼都有一个实质性的平台，因此它们实际上充当了门廊。这是一个存放东西、和几个朋友闲逛、烤牛排并结识下方巷子里邻居的地方。这些木制台阶和门廊在 20 世纪初开始涌现，作为紧急逃生的手段被螺栓固定在建筑物上，因为芝加哥对火灾有着非常合理的恐惧。它们是功利主义的事情，后来演变得更多。似乎可以说，绝大多数这些都不是由建筑师设计的，我位于洛根广场的公寓楼后门的那座结构太不健全了，
I don't think it was designed at all. This week 99% invisible producers and friends of the show will be sharing more stories about vernacular architecture we love from our hometowns. But with an emphasis on examples that may be a bit chaggier and have somewhat more functional origins. They may not be the first things people call beautiful, but they're beautiful to us, and
我觉得它根本就不是设计出来的。本周，99% Invisible 的制作人和节目的朋友将分享更多关于我们喜爱的来自家乡的本土建筑的故事。但重点是那些可能有点破旧且起源更具功能性的例子。它们可能不是人们称之为美丽的第一件事，但它们对我们来说是美丽的，并且
they are essential parts of the places they're built. A verse is producer Emmett Fitzgerald. I grew up in Central Vermont, and in old house on a hill, it was built in the 1840s, a little farmhouse from a time when most people were farmers. Over the years, the house grew as my parents tacked on a room here and a room there, but in the kitchen you can still see the original spruce beams, with tiny curly-cute tunnels carved by 19th century bugs. There are a lot of old farmhouses like mine along the dirt roads of Vermont.
它们是它们建造的地方不可或缺的一部分。我是制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。我在佛蒙特州中部的一座山上的老房子里长大，它建于 1840 年代，是一个小农舍，那是大多数人都是农民的时代。多年来，随着我父母在这里加建一个房间，在那里加建一个房间，房子越来越大，但在厨房里你仍然可以看到最初的云杉梁，上面有 19 世纪的虫子雕刻出的微小、卷曲的可爱隧道。在佛蒙特州的泥土路上，有很多像我这样老旧的农舍。
Most of them were not designed by architects, but local carpenters who followed a few different traditional styles. And like mine, most of these houses have grown and changed over the centuries, adapting to the needs of new generations. As a result, the farmhouses of Vermont don't have a single consistent look,
它们大多不是由建筑师设计的，而是由遵循几种不同传统风格的当地木匠设计的。和我的房子一样，这些房子大多在几个世纪里不断生长和变化，适应着新一代人的需求。因此，佛蒙特州的农舍并没有单一连贯的外观，
but there is one bizarre architectural feature that you will find on lots of them, windows that have been turned 45 degrees. They're just like regular windows, but coccyde, tilted, so that they run on a diagonal parallel with the roof line, rather than straight up and down. Growing up, I would see these windows all the time. Usually, it's spot them on an old looking farmhouse
但你会在许多农舍上发现一个奇怪的建筑特征：旋转了 45 度的窗户。它们就像普通的窗户一样，但是歪斜的、倾斜的，使它们沿着与屋顶线平行的对角线延伸，而不是笔直上下。在成长过程中，我经常看到这些窗户。通常，我在一个看起来很旧的农舍上发现它们
that might have an even older looking barn lilting in the field out back. They always looked kind of otherworldly to me, like little glitches in the matrix. But to be honest, I didn't think that much about them. They were all over Vermont. And I kind of assumed that they were all over other places, too. It did not feel strange to me at all.
后院的田野里可能还有一个看起来更古老的谷仓。它们在我看来总是有点超现实，就像黑客帝国里的一个小故障。但老实说，我并没有多想它们。它们遍布佛蒙特州。我有点认为它们在其他地方也到处都是。我一点也不觉得奇怪。
My friend Alice actually had one of these windows in her bedroom growing up. And on a recent visit home from Chicago, she posted a few pictures of her childhood house to Instagram. Like, everybody here, to a tea, was commenting thing, like that window was crazy, that's a crazy window. And I was like, is it? Like in my mind, I was like, oh, I grew up with this window.
我的朋友爱丽丝在成长过程中，卧室里其实就有这样一扇窗户。最近她从芝加哥回家探亲时，在 Instagram 上发布了几张她童年房子的照片。就像这里的每个人，毫无例外，都评论说，那扇窗户太疯狂了，那是一扇疯狂的窗户。然后我就想，是吗？就像在我的脑海里，我心想，哦，我是伴随着这扇窗户长大的。
Like I didn't realize it was crazy. It turns out that these crooked windows are found almost entirely in Vermont. They go by a few different names, but are probably most commonly referred to as witch windows. Legend has it, the windows were tilted on a diagonal in order to prevent witches from flying into the house on their broomsticks. A sort of architectural defense strategy. And I grew up thinking it's called a witch window because witches can't fly in it.
就像我没有意识到它有多疯狂一样。事实证明，这些歪斜的窗户几乎只在佛蒙特州找到。它们有几个不同的名字，但最常被称为女巫窗。传说这些窗户呈对角线倾斜，是为了防止女巫骑着扫帚飞进房子里。这是一种建筑防御策略。我从小就认为它被称为女巫窗，因为女巫无法从里面飞进来。
So I was saved from witches. Why exactly a competent witch would be thwarted by a diagonal window is never quite explained. Because they can only fly straight, I guess. But there you go. Did that bring you a piece of my- Um, honestly, yes. I grew up a very fearful child of paranormal things and the like surroundings of my house are kind of spooky too.
所以我免受了女巫的伤害。为什么一个称职的女巫会被一个对角线窗户难住，这一点从来没有完全解释清楚。因为它们只能笔直飞行，我猜。但就是这样。这给你带来了一点……嗯，老实说，是的。我从小就是一个非常害怕超自然现象的孩子，我家周围的环境也有点毛骨悚然。
Like dark woods and you don't know what's in there. So like, yeah, really any sort of extra protection helps predict this or dig a list of things about now, but it's true. And like I said, these tilted windows, which you see all over Vermont, have a few different names. Did you ever hear them refer to as coffin windows? No, wait, why were they called coffin windows?
比如黑色的树林，你不知道里面有什么。所以，是的，真的任何额外的保护都有助于预测这一点，或者现在列出一堆事情，但这是真的。就像我说的，这些在佛蒙特州随处可见的倾斜窗户有几个不同的名字。你有没有听说过它们被称为棺材窗？不，等等，为什么它们被称为棺材窗？
Okay, so this one makes even less sense in my opinion, but the story goes that they were called coffin windows because they enabled people to slide a coffin out of a second story window if someone happened to die upstairs. I don't really understand how that would work physically or why you would bring the coffin upstairs rather than just bringing the body downstairs, but the name has stuck around and added another layer of general spookiness to these windows. Now I had fully assumed that Alice's Witch Window or Coffin Window had been a part of the
好吧，在我看来，这个名字更没有意义，但故事是这样的，它们被称为棺材窗，因为如果有人不幸在楼上去世，它们可以让人们把棺材从二楼的窗户滑出去。我真的不明白这在物理上是如何起作用的，或者为什么你要把棺材搬上楼而不是直接把尸体搬下楼，但这个名字一直流传下来，并为这些窗户增添了另一层普遍的诡异感。现在我完全以为爱丽丝的女巫窗或棺材窗是该建筑最初建造的一部分，
house's original construction, or maybe some 19th century renovation. Their house was definitely old, from the same era as my parents, and people aren't exactly out there installing new Witch windows. At that's what I thought I actually asked my mom about it and she said that there used to be like a smaller window in there and then I was born and they wanted to have a window that a person could fit through just in case of emergencies so she wow, she had that put in. Which means that Alice's witch window was only a few decades old and was installed not
或者也许是 19 世纪的一些翻新。他们的房子绝对很旧，和我父母的时代属于同一时期，人们可不会随便跑出去安装新的女巫窗。这就是我所想的，我其实问过我妈妈这件事，她说以前里面有一个比较小的窗户，然后我出生了，他们想要一个万一发生紧急情况人可以穿过去的窗户，所以她……哇，那是她装上的。这意味着爱丽丝的女巫窗只有几十年历史，安装的初衷并不是
to prevent witches from entering the house or to get coffins out, but to give little Alice an emergency exit in case of a fire. Yeah, she put it in. That's so interesting. You have to be like, mom. Yeah, you probably should. I'm sorry, I'm not helpful at all.
为了防止女巫进入房子或把棺材搬出去，而是为了给小爱丽丝在发生火灾时提供一个紧急出口。是的，是她装上的。太有趣了。你必须对妈妈说：是的，你可能应该这么做。对不起，我一点用都没有。
Come or the mom. Yeah. And it? Hey, Nancy. Hi. How are you? I'm good. How are you?
来吧，妈妈。是的。还有吗？嘿，南希。嗨。你好吗？我很好。你呢？
This is Nancy, Mother of Alice. And as I learned in this conversation, the former architectural historian of the state of Vermont. So yeah, I probably should have just called her first. So Alice made a pledge that I put in that window. That's not original. Nancy confirmed that she wanted to install the window to give Alice an escape route out the bedroom. But there was a problem. There just wasn't enough room. Like a lot of old farmhouses in Vermont, the main part of the house is only one and a
这是南希，爱丽丝的母亲。正如我在这次谈话中了解到的那样，她是佛蒙特州前州建筑历史学家。所以，是的，我可能应该先给她打电话。所以爱丽丝发誓我装了那扇窗户。那不是原装的。南希证实，她想安装这扇窗户是为了给爱丽丝提供一条从卧室逃生的路线。但有一个问题。空间实在不够。就像佛蒙特州的许多老农舍一样，房子的主楼部分只有一楼半高。
half-stories tall. And then there's a back wing that's even shorter. And so Alice's second floor room was tucked under the slope of the Gable roof. And there just wasn't enough space for a regular vertical window. But Nancy, being an expert in the historical architecture of Vermont had an idea. I thought, well, I'll just use the old Vermont solution, which is to put in a window with an angle like that. I asked the carpenters to put it in. I thought I was a little bit crazy.
后面还有一个更矮的侧翼。所以爱丽丝二楼的房间夹在斜面屋顶的斜坡下。根本没有足够的空间安装普通的垂直窗户。但南希作为佛蒙特州历史建筑专家，想到了一个主意。我想，好吧，我只用老佛蒙特州的解决办法，那就是装一个有这种角度的窗户。我请木匠把它装上。我想我有点疯狂。
Nancy says that this is the real reason these crooked windows exist in the first place. It has nothing to do with witches or coffins. It was just a clever architectural workaround, a simple, cheap solution for how to get a window into a space where one doesn't naturally fit. You could build a dormer, but that's expensive. And so at some point, some clever carpenter and Vermont had the idea to just salvage a regular window and turn it on an angle. And then the idea just spread as a practical solution.
南希说，这就是这些歪斜的窗户最初存在的真正原因。这与女巫或棺材毫无关系。这只是一种聪明的建筑变通方法，一种简单、廉价的解决方案，用于如何在自然无法容纳窗户的空间中安装窗户。你可以建一个老虎窗，但那很贵。因此，在某个时候，佛蒙特州某个聪明的木匠萌生了这样一个想法：回收一个普通的窗户，把它转到一个角度。然后这个想法作为一个实际的解决方案传播开来。
So, you know, it wasn't like it was a decorative feature of old houses. It was, I think, a very practical old Yankee solution to getting light and air into that room that otherwise doesn't have enough wall space to put a window to the outside. There's actually one more name that these windows sometimes go by. For Mont Windows. It might not sound as cool as which windows, but I think it's a pretty good name. For an architectural feature that emerged from the collective genius of a bunch of anonymous fermenters. For our multi-part 500 episode milestone vernacular spectacular, a lot of the staff have done stories that are focused on residential and personal architecture that's affected them.
所以，你知道，它不像是一个老房子的装饰特征。我认为，这是一个非常实用、古老的洋基解决方案，用来将光线和空气引入那个否则没有足够墙壁空间向外开窗的房间里。其实这些窗户有时还有另一个名字。佛蒙特窗。听起来可能没有女巫窗那么酷，但我觉得这是一个相当不错名字。对于一个从一群匿名的佛蒙特人的集体智慧中涌现出来的建筑特征。为了我们庆祝 500 集的系列节目“本土建筑奇观”，许多员工都制作了关于影响他们的住宅和个人建筑的故事。
But for the show and longtime contributor Katie Thornton is here to talk about the thing that she loves in her neighborhood in Minneapolis that is not residential at all. It is industrial. In fact, it is like aggressively. Yeah, aggressively industrial is the perfect description. And certainly it is the architectural feature that dominates my neighborhood, stretches above homes, above trees, and I'm talking about these huge, concrete towers that we know as grain silos. When I think a lot of people picture grain silos, they're like driving on a highway in the Midwest, and they see one in the distance in this lone tower,
但对于本节目而言，长期撰稿人凯蒂·桑顿来到这里，谈论她所喜爱的明尼阿波利斯街区中完全不是住宅的东西。它是工业的。事实上，它是那样的富有攻击性。是的，富有攻击性的工业是完美的描述。当然，它是主导我街区的建筑特征，延伸到房屋上方、树木上方，我说的是这些我们所知的巨大的混凝土塔，也就是谷仓。当我想象很多人心目中的谷仓时，他们就像是在中西部的公路上开车，在远处看到这座孤零零的塔，
but this is not what is going on in your neighborhood. This is something a little bit more massive. Right, yes, so I live in Minneapolis. And so if you can imagine like one of those towers, but they usually are sort of domed, if you see about in farm, chop off the dome and just bunch them all together, like rose and rose side by side. They're these sort of massive concrete compounds that just are used to store tons and
但这并不是你街区里发生的事情。这是一个更庞大的东西。没错，是的，我住在明尼阿波利斯。如果你能想象其中一座塔，但它们通常有点呈穹顶状，如果你在农场里看到它，砍掉穹顶，然后把它们像一排排并排挤在一起。它们是那种巨大的混凝土大院，只用于储存成吨成吨的谷物，绵延数个街区。你目前就生活在其中一座的阴影下。那种感觉是怎样的？
tons of grain and stretching for blocks and blocks and blocks. And you currently live under the shadow of one. What is that like? Yeah, I love it. I've lived here for a number of years now. It means that my garden is always a little bit pitiful. I'm robbed of some pretty precious hours of sunlight every day, but it is still very much worth it. And the silos, it's like, they're kind of funny. They're like, almost to apologize for, like, oh, sorry, your guard insects.
是的，我喜欢。我在这里已经住了好几年了。这意味着我的花园总是有点凄凉。我每天都被剥夺了一些非常珍贵的日照时间，但它仍然非常值得。而且这些谷仓，就像是，它们有点滑稽。它们就像是在为之道歉，比如，哦，抱歉，你的花园虫子。
It's like, here, we spilled a bunch of grain all over the train tracks that are adjacent to the silos. So you have this, like, annoyingly idyllic surplus of bunnies and other little critters. And then, in turn, that means there's red-tailed hawks and falcons who live up in the crevices and the cracks of the silos, and they're just eating very well. You know, I think I picture you living near an abandoned silo for some reason, and there are tons of abandoned ones, but yours is full of grain.
就像是，这里，我们在与谷仓相邻的铁轨上洒了大量的谷物。所以你会得到一种令人恼火的、田园诗般过剩的兔子和其他小动物。然后，反过来，这意味着有红尾鹰和猎鹰生活在谷仓的缝隙里，它们吃得非常好。你知道，不知为什么，我脑海中浮现出你住在废弃谷仓附近的画面，虽然有成吨的废弃谷仓，但你的谷仓里装满了谷物。
That's actually really cool. So why are there so many grain silos in Minneapolis? Like, what was going on when their boom happened? I think that's really gets to like one of the reasons why I like the silos is that it's this big visual reminder of why the city grew in the first place. Um, the area has been home to indigenous people from Alineas since long before, long before white colonists settled here. But starting in the 1800s, this virginicity of Minneapolis was built on the Mississippi River, on the area where there's
这其实真的很酷。那么，为什么明尼阿波利斯会有这么多谷仓呢？当它们的繁荣发生时，这里到底发生了什么？我认为这确实触及了我喜欢这些谷仓的原因之一，因为它是这座城市最初发展原因的一个巨大的视觉提醒。嗯，在白人殖民者在这里定居之前很久，这个地区就一直是阿利内亚原住民的家园。但从 19 世纪开始，明尼阿波利斯的这个处女地建在密西西比河上，
the only sort of significant natural waterfall on the entirety of the Mississippi. And eventually, they were able to use the power of that waterfall to power flower mills, where they ground up wheat, which was grown in the area on your vibe. So, milling became the city's biggest industry really quickly. And as the railroads were built, more and more unprocessed grain could come in from farms from throughout the region and get processed by the mills in the city,
密西西比河全流域唯一显著的天然瀑布。最终，他们能够利用瀑布的力量来驱动面粉厂，在那里他们研磨小麦，这些小麦是在你所在的地区种植的。因此，面粉加工迅速成为该市最大的产业。随着铁路的修建，越来越多的未加工谷物可以从全地区的农场运来，由城市的磨坊加工，
and then be stored in silos like the one near me, or shipped down the river, or shipped out by train. So there's this sort of interconnected man-made and natural systems that all sort of converge and coincide right here. And then you add to it that these crops are seasonal, so you get a whole bunch at once, and you have to deal with it.
然后储存在像我附近那样的谷仓里，或者顺流而下运走，或者用火车运输出去。所以这里存在着一种相互联系的人造和自然系统，它们都在这里交汇和重合。然后你再加上这些农作物是季节性的，所以你一下子得到一大堆，你必须处理它。
So you have to find a way to store it somehow. Yeah, and so in order to sort of solve this problem storing grain, like farmers for a long, long time would just store it on their property. For the most part, since the 1800s, the buildings that held grain were wooden and square, Like many buildings that you may be aware are built. But there was sort of this problem, which is that like when they were filled, there would be these air pockets in the corners. They wouldn't just fill out, you know,
所以你必须想办法以某种方式储存它。是的，为了解决储存谷物这个问题，像农民很长一段时间以来都会直接把它储存在自己的地产上。在大多数情况下，自 19 世纪以来，存放谷物的建筑物都是木制的方形建筑，就像你可能知道的许多建筑物一样。但存在一个问题，那就是当它们被填满时，角落里会有这些气囊。它们不会只是填满，你知道的，
like a cat fills out every corner of a cardboard box, you know, it would just like not reach into the corners. And then this little bit of air would lead to all of this grain rot. And so that was sort of a problem for farmers. It was a problem for grain merchants. And also wooden silos were just super prone to catching on fire. So this grain merchant, Frank Peevy, sick of losing his grain to rot,
就像猫填满纸箱的每一个角落一样，你知道的，它就是无法触及角落。然后这小部分空气就会导致所有这些谷物腐烂。这对农民来说是个问题。这对谷物商人来说是个问题。而且木制谷仓也极易着火。所以这位谷物商人弗兰克·皮维（Frank Peevy），厌倦了因腐烂而损失谷物，
didn't want to pay these high fire insurance premiums. And so he wanted to figure out how to store the grain in a different way. And so he brought along this contractor named Charles Haglin, and they wanted to try something different. Well, what is flammable? Let's try concrete, which hadn't been done before. And also, you know, this whole square building thing, it isn't really working. The corners are the problem.
不想支付这些高昂的火灾保险费。所以他想弄清楚如何用不同的方式储存谷物。于是他找到了这位名叫查尔斯·哈格林（Charles Haglin）的承包商，他们想尝试一些不同的东西。嗯，什么东西是易燃的？让我们试试混凝土，以前没这么做过。而且，你知道，整个方形建筑物的做法根本行不通。角落才是问题所在。
Let's just make it round. And so in the late 1800s, they decided to build up a prototype of a cylindrical, concrete grain silo to sort of prove that their idea could work. You know, the typology of a cylinder makes so much sense. It's almost surprising that they didn't come up with a sooner. Yeah. But I think you're right. It did surprise me.
把它做成圆的吧。因此，在 19 世纪末，他们决定建造一个圆柱形混凝土谷仓的原型，以证明他们的想法是可行的。你知道，圆柱体的类型太有意义了。甚至有点惊讶他们没有早点想出来。是的。但我认为你是对的。确实让我感到惊讶。
It didn't come up sooner. And honestly, what surprised me even more is that like even when they came up with this idea at the tail end of the 1800s, everyone was like terrible idea. Going to be an absolute flop. What are you thinking? Like they started to build this structure. And before they could even finish the prototype, people had dubbed it PV's Folly, which is just like a very cruel thing to do.
它没有更早出现。老实说，更让我惊讶的是，甚至当他们在 19 世纪末提出这个想法时，每个人都觉得这是一个糟糕的主意。注定要彻底失败。你在想什么？就像他们开始建造这个结构一样。在他们甚至还没完成原型之前，人们就把它称为“皮维的愚蠢”，这简直是一种非常残酷的做法。
It's not like it had failed. He just literally wasn't done. So people just were like, this is stupid ideas. This is never gonna work. And they thought that either this cement wouldn't be strong enough, like the sheer volume of the grain that was pushing out on the silo from the inside would just be enough to force it
这并不是说它失败了。他只是字面意义上还没建完。所以人们只是觉得，这是一个愚蠢的主意。这永远不会成功。他们认为，要么是这种水泥不够坚强，就像从内部向外推谷仓的谷物绝对体量将足以迫使它
to crack or burst. Which, you know, I guess valid concern, I would probably have similar concerns about wood. Also, they thought that while this airtight tower is gonna create a vacuum, and so when you open a door at the bottom and let the grain spill out, which is how you get the grain out,
裂开或爆裂。你知道的，我想这算是个合理的担忧，我对木材可能也会有类似的担忧。此外，他们认为，虽然这个气密塔会产生真空，所以当你打开底部的门让谷物溢出时，这是你取出谷物的方式，
it's just gonna implode, it's just gonna to implode, it's just going to collapse. People thought it was a terrible idea. Okay, so they build their prototype and people are skeptical what happens next. Well, as you can probably imagine, based on how grain silos look today, PV proved to them all wrong. There was a day set where they were going to fill their demonstration piece and hundreds of people gathered to watch this drama because this is the big news of the day. The silo is going to explode.
它只会内爆，它只会内爆，它只会崩溃。人们认为这是一个糟糕的主意。好吧，他们建造了原型，人们对此持怀疑态度，接下来会发生什么？好吧，正如你大概能想象的那样，根据今天谷仓的样子，皮维向所有人证明他们都错了。有一天，他们要装满他们的演示件，数百人聚集在一起观看这场戏剧，因为这是当天的重大新闻。谷仓要爆炸了。
It's going to collapse. It's going to, whatever. So they cordoned people off from this supposed blast zone. It was this whole to-do. The New York Times even sent a reporter out. And then what are you going to report on? It went off without a hitch. And then they began to crop up everywhere. Everywhere. So the silos near me were sort of built
它要倒塌了。它会怎么样。所以他们把人们从这个所谓的爆破区隔离出来。这真是一场大惊小怪。《纽约时报》甚至派了一名记者出来。然后你打算报道什么？结果一切顺利。然后它们开始到处涌现。到处都是。所以我附近的谷仓大概建于
shortly after this very first concrete cylindrical grain silo. And they were really built to last, like they were not built with any consideration for people's aesthetic desires necessarily, but they were definitely built to last, hence still living by them. But as you mentioned, milling is no longer the primary source of industrial income when it comes to Minneapolis. So what happens when you have this robust piece of industrial infrastructure that can last 110 years know, 110 years when there is no longer grain to be milled. So, you know, for those silos that are still operational, they're one of the rare pieces of industrial design that still operates as intended, like 100 plus years later, which is
在这个第一座混凝土圆柱形谷仓建成后不久。它们的建造经久耐用，就像它们的建造根本没有考虑人们对审美的需求一样，但它们的建造绝对是为了经久耐用，因此我仍然住在它们旁边。但正如你所提到的，对于明尼阿波利斯来说， milling（面粉加工）不再是工业收入的主要来源。那么，当你有这样一个可以使用 110 年的强大工业基础设施时，当不再有谷物需要加工时，会发生什么呢？所以，你知道，对于那些仍在运营的谷仓来说，它们是罕见的工业设计作品之一，在 100 多年后仍然按预期运行，这
pretty darn remarkable. But for those that aren't operational, they've proven really difficult to repurpose. I love to see the silos that have been repurposed across the country, some have been retrofitted as hotels. There are brewery facilities. There's some condos. There's even some condos here in Minneapolis. You don't even recognize it when you walk past.
相当了不起。但对于那些没有运营的谷仓来说，它们被证明很难重新用于其他目的。我很高兴看到全国各地被重新利用的谷仓，有些被改造成了酒店。有啤酒厂设施。有一些公寓。明尼阿波利斯甚至还有一些公寓。当你走过时甚至认不出它来。
It's like, I bike past this one building that was a retrofitted grain silo that is now condos for years and years of my childhood. And it took me until this year, this story, to be like, oh, that was a silo. Oh, wow. You know, I've heard it said on the show, good design is 99% invisible, and I could not agree more. But I just kind of happened to live at one of those junctures where it's just unavoidably visible. And it's sort of this like relay station
就像，我骑车经过一栋经过改造的谷仓建筑，它现在是公寓，伴随了我童年的好几年。直到今年，直到这个故事，我才恍然大悟，哦，那是个谷仓。哦，哇。你知道，我曾在节目中听到过这样一句话：好的设计是 99% 隐形的，我对此不能同意更多。但我恰好生活在这样交汇点之一，它在这里不可避免地可见。它有点像这个宏大城市设计中的中继站，
in this big urban design where like our infrastructure has to come up for air, it has to be seen. And personally, I kind of like to get a little look behind the scenes at what makes a city tick or even just what used to make a city tick. Well, thank you so much for talking with us and sharing your love of grain silos. Thanks, Roman.
我们的基础设施必须浮出水面透气，它必须被看见。就我个人而言，我有点喜欢一窥幕后，看看是什么让一座城市运转，或者甚至只是看看过去是什么让一座城市运转。好吧，非常感谢你与我们交谈并分享你对谷仓的热爱。谢谢你，罗曼。
Thanks for having me on. And congratulations on a 500 and 501st episode. Thank you. I'm amazed myself. Amazing. The global appetite for talking about grain silos and maintenance, whole cover, was stronger than I thought. Well, I'm honored to be a small part of it.
谢谢你邀请我参加。祝贺第 500 集和第 501 集。谢谢。我自己也很惊叹。太棒了。全球对谈论谷仓和维护（整个封面）的热情比我想象的要强烈。好吧，我很荣幸能成为其中的一小部分。
We're going to shout at the sky with Jason Dalyone after this. Here's producer Jason Dillion. A few weeks back, my dad texted me this video that he shot on his phone. Another 5 o'clock summer storm is ripping through the east side of Orlando, and my dad, well, he opened up a bottle of wine a bit early. I can hear it in his voice, to octaves up, yelling commands at the wind. I love when my dad sends me these weather updates, partly because they're incredible to watch, rain coming down like an open faucet, palm trees bending till they nearly break, but also partly because of where he is when he films these videos.
之后我们将与杰森·戴利昂一起向天空呐喊。这是制作人杰森·狄龙。几周前，我爸爸给我发了这个他在手机上拍摄的视频。又一场下午 5 点的夏日风暴席卷了奥兰多东侧，而我爸爸，嗯，他有点提前打开了一瓶酒。我能从他的声音里听出来，音调高了两个八度，对着风大喊大叫。我喜欢我爸爸给我发这些天气更新，一部分是因为它们看起来不可思议，雨像开着的自来水一样倾盆而下，棕榈树弯曲得几乎要折断，但另一部分原因是因为他拍摄这些视频时的所在位置。
He's almost always out back on what most people might call the screened in porch, But down in Florida, we take the screened in porch to a whole new level. We have Lenise. Hi, Lenise, call your mom. I grew up around Lenise, bouncing from one to the next away some kids jump from backyard to backyard or basement to basement. That's because in Florida, especially in the newly developed areas, you can find Lennies everywhere. Fly into the Orlando International Airport, and as you descend, yes, you'll see some of the worst urban sprawl America has to offer, but also Lennies.
他几乎总是在后院，大多数人可能会称之为带纱窗的门廊，但在佛罗里达州，我们将带纱窗的门廊提升到了一个全新的水平。我们有露台（Lanai）。嗨，露台，叫你妈妈来。我是伴随着露台长大的，从一个露台蹦到另一个露台，就像有些孩子从一个后院蹦到另一个后院，或者从一个地下室蹦到另一个地下室一样。那是因为在佛罗里达州，特别是在新开发的地区，你到处都能找到露台。飞往奥兰多国际机场，当你下降时，是的，你会看到美国所能提供的最糟糕的城市蔓延，但也会看到露台。
This space that's both inside and outside, where you can invite the element into your home or keep nature at bay. And maybe you've never come across when yourself, or only heard the word thrown around on an episode of Golden Girls. This door through your room, she's out on the lanae. I suppose you're wondering why a man like Sunny Ball. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, on the lanae. But to me, and apparently the blanche,
这个既在室内又在室外的空间，你可以在这里把元素请进你的家，或者把大自然拒之门外。也许你从未自己遇到过露台，或者只是在《黄金女郎》的一集中听到过这个词。这扇穿过你房间的门，她在露台外面。我想你在想为什么像桑尼·鲍尔这样的人。是的，是的，是的，在露台上。但对我来说，显然还有布兰奇，
the Florida lani is quintessential to the whole Sunshine State experience. If you've never seen a Florida lani, you might think it sounds kind of fancy or exotic, but really the structure is simple. It's an outdoor living space that's typically box shaped and has this mesh screening closure separating the home from the yard.
佛罗里达的露台是整个阳光之州体验的核心。如果你从来没见过佛罗里达的露台，你可能会觉得它听起来有点花哨或异国情调，但实际上它的结构很简单。它是一个通常呈盒状的户外生活空间，并有一个网眼纱窗将房屋与庭院隔开。
On the outside, it sort of looks like a baseball batting cage. But on the inside, it gives off this vibe of a living room wearing boat shoes. Estetics aside, the lani is a solution to some common Florida problems. For instance, that screening closure, it's there to keep the mosquitoes off you. Not to mention all the other bugs and animals
从外面看，它有点像棒球击球笼。但在内部，它散发着一种穿着船鞋的客厅的氛围抛开美观不谈，露台是解决一些常见佛罗里达问题的方法。例如，那个纱窗，它的存在是为了防止蚊子叮咬你。更不用说所有其他你可能不希望在周围的虫子和动物了
you probably don't want around. Are medillos, lizards, snakes, and gators. In some of the newer constructions from the housing boom of the early 2000s, you'll see linoys with ingrown pools built inside the screen enclosure. This helps keep your pool from becoming just another floor to swamp.
犰狳、蜥蜴、蛇和短吻鳄。在 2000 年代初期住房繁荣时期的一些较新的建筑中，你会看到露台内建造了嵌入式游泳池，这些泳池位于纱窗封闭空间内。这有助于防止你的游泳池变成又一个青蛙沼泽。
And if you have a little bit more change in your pocket, you'll see Linai's that are fully souped up, equipped with outdoor kitchens and enough space to host gigantic dinner parties. So depending on your tax bracket, it can be a modest chair or two with a table in the back corner of your home or a Miami vice-style extravaganza. When I think of Lanai, I think of my parents Florida Lanai.
如果你口袋里零钱更多一点，你会看到功能齐全的露台，配备了户外厨房，并且有足够大的空间来举办巨大的晚宴。因此，根据你的税收阶梯，它可能是你家后角落里带桌子的简陋椅子或两把椅子，也可能是迈阿密风云风格的奢华盛会。当我想到露台时，我想到了我父母的佛罗里达露台。
But for Dean Sakamoto who studied the history of the structure, he takes it back to its indigenous roots. The Lanai, as you saw, as you know, it's a native Hawaiian word. It's really a basic, a primal structure, like a four-posted structure, just with enough cover to keep the sun out. Dean co-authored a book about one of Hawaii's most renowned architects, Vladimir Asipov. He says Asipov helped modernize and popularize the LNI throughout the mid-20th century. Mr. Asipov, although he's Russian by birth, he grew up in Japan.
但对于研究该结构历史的迪恩·萨卡莫托（Dean Sakamoto）来说，他把它追溯到了它的原住民根源。正如你所看到的，正如你所知，露台是一个夏威夷土著词。它实际上是一个基本的、原始的结构，就像一个四根柱子的结构，只有足够的遮盖物来挡住阳光。迪恩合著了一本关于夏威夷最著名建筑师之一弗拉基米尔·阿西波夫（Vladimir Ossipov）的书。他说，阿西波夫帮助在整个 20 世纪中期使露台现代化并普及。阿西波夫先生，虽然他出生于俄罗斯，但他是在日本长大的。
And so he grew up in a Japanese style home. And if you look at Japanese architecture, the domestic Japanese house, there's a space called the Engawa. The Engawa is a sort of precursor to the LNI. It's a narrow, covered hallway built in between the interior rooms of an old Japanese home and the garden. Left open, the Angawa allows for natural light in the air to circulate.
所以他在日本风格的家庭中长大。如果你看看日本建筑，即日式住宅，有一个空间叫做“缘侧”（Engawa）。“缘侧”有点像露台的前身。它是建在老式日式住宅的室内房间与庭院之间的一个狭窄的带屋顶的走廊。保持开放，“缘侧”允许自然光和空气流通。
The space has this incentive to coexist with nature, not resisted. An idea Asapop used for hislinize on the islands. When he came to Hawaii, he realized that the Japanese house to perhaps more appropriate in Hawaii than Japan, because of climate. You know, Japan gets cold. Asapop designed hundreds of luxury homes in Hawaii. In almost all of them, the Lanai is the crown jewel of the house, his canvas to showcase
这个空间具有与自然共存而不是抗拒的动力。阿西波夫在岛上的露台设计中运用了这个想法。当他来到夏威夷时，他意识到由于气候原因，日式住宅也许比在日本更适合夏威夷。你知道，日本天气寒冷。阿西波夫在夏威夷设计了数百栋豪华住宅。在几乎所有的住宅中，露台都是房子的皇冠明珠，是展示他的画布
a new style of tropical modernism. Asapop made his imprint on Hawaiian architecture throughout the 1950s and 60s. During that time, Hawaii itself was changing, turning from an American territory with an economy based on agriculture to a state with a booming tourism industry. And with that tourism, came large-scale developments. Famously at a press conference, Asapov announced the quote, War on Ugliness, when he saw cheap cookie cutter-style housing creeping onto the shores of Honolulu. For locals trying to attract mainland travelers, the Lenai was a defining feature of the state's architectural identity.
一种热带现代主义的新风格。阿西波夫在 20 世纪 50 年代和 60 年代在夏威夷建筑界留下了自己的印记。在此期间，夏威夷本身也在发生变化，从一个以农业为基础经济的美属领地变成了一个拥有蓬勃发展旅游业的州。随着旅游业的发展，大规模开发随之而来。众所周知，在一场新闻发布会上，阿西波夫宣布了所谓的“丑陋战争”，当时他看到廉价的千篇一律的住房潜入檀香山的海岸。对于试图吸引大陆游客的当地人来说，露台是该州建筑认同的一个决定性特征。
It was unique, a space that embodied the virtues of island life. Around the same time of a wise transformation, mentions of a tropical room borrowed from Pacific Islanders appeared in newspapers around Florida. One article from 1964 raves about the lini. It says it's the most exciting concept and indoor outdoor living ever presented to the Central Florida new home buyer.
它是独特的，一个体现了岛屿生活美德的空间。大约在夏威夷转型期的同时，佛罗里达各地的报纸上出现了借用自太平洋岛民的热带房间的提及。1964 年的一篇文章对露台赞不绝口。它说这是有史以来向佛罗里达州中部新购房者提出的最令人兴奋的室内外生活概念。
Another highlights it as a way to quote, plan for happy living. You can see how the idea is exciting and new, but you can also see how it differs from an Asapovlin eye. While Asapovlin eyes were highbrow, custom made and built to take into account the cooling trade winds and stormy Kona winds of Hawaii, the Floridalin eye was a completely different species, more rudimentary and undefined. Much like Hawaii, Florida was going through its own transformation with its own housing boom. In some of the floor plans from the 60s and 70s, you can feel the
另一篇文章强调它是“规划幸福生活”的一种方式。你可以看到这个想法是如何令人兴奋和新颖的，但你也可以看到它与阿西波夫的露台有何不同。虽然阿西波夫的露台档次高、定制建造，并且经过建造以考虑到夏威夷凉爽的信风和多风的科纳风，但佛罗里达的露台则完全是另一个物种，更加简陋和模糊不清。就像夏威夷一样，佛罗里达州也在经历着自己的转型，伴随着自己的住房热潮。在 60 年代和 70 年代的一些平面图中，你能感受到
developer's hand of excitement trying to see just where a Lanai can be squeezed in. Today, builders have taken it a step further, more or less standardizing the placement and look of a lani so that each one is nearly indistinguishable from the next. And the homes are packed together so tightly that the lani has become a way to effectively offer an outdoor space without giving the home an actual yard. If Ossipov's war on ugliness and cookie cutter housing started in Hawaii, it ended in defeat in Orlando. But still, I can't quite shake this fondness for this strange fluridian architectural creature. Objectively, the typical Florida lini is kind of bulky and ugly and bad in KG, but I have this fairy don't make fun of my ugly puppy feeling about them.
开发商试图看看究竟在哪里可以挤出一个露台的兴奋之手。今天，建筑商更进一步，或多或少地将露台的位置和外观标准化，以至于每一个露台都与下一个几乎没有区别。房屋挤得如此紧密，以至于露台已经成为一种有效提供户外空间的方式，而无需给房屋一个实际的院子。如果阿西波夫的丑陋战争和千篇一律的住房始于夏威夷，它在奥兰多以失败告终。不过，我还是无法摆脱对这个奇怪的佛罗里达建筑生物的喜爱。客观地说，典型的佛罗里达露台有点笨重、丑陋且俗气，但我对它们有一种“别取笑我的丑小狗”的感觉。
But I have this fairy don't make fun of my ugly puppy feeling about them. In Florida, a place where most people move to unabashedly have more, the lini feels like the most appropriate place to indulge in that excess. And in my family, there's a spirit to the space. It's where we gather at the end of a long day to collectively shake ourselves loose. It's where we sit around for hours on end playing dominoes for dollars. Listening to Bajata and Marengi while others sit around and tell stories about people long gone, drinking corona and mama hwana and to wear fresh out. Even now when I go home to visit, the long talks with my mom where I finally get to sit her down and ask her, hey, how are you? And tell my dad that I'm doing okay, that I'm figuring it out, that I'm excited about
但在佛罗里达，这个大多数人搬来是为了毫无顾忌地拥有更多东西的地方，露台感觉像是放纵这种过度行为最合适的场所。在我的家庭中，这个空间有一种精神。这是我们在漫长的一天结束时聚在一起集体释放自我的地方。这是我们连续坐上几个小时玩多米诺骨牌赢取美元的地方。听着巴恰塔（Bachata）和梅伦格（Merengue），而其他人则坐在一起讲述关于早已离去的人的故事，喝着科罗娜（Corona）和玛玛华安娜（Mamajuana），直到鞋子湿透。即使现在我回家探望，与妈妈的长谈，在那里我终于可以让她坐下来问她，嘿，最近怎么样？并告诉爸爸我过得很好，我在摸索着前进，我对
this little life I'm starting. Those talks do not happen at the dinner table. They happen in the lini. And yes, even though I only get down a visit a few times a year, I still love to watch a storm roll in. To feel the temperature in the air drop as the rain hits the hot pavement, counting the time between the cracks of thunder and streaks of lightning, wondering if that last one touched the ground. And probably my favorite part
我开始的这种小生活感到兴奋。这些谈话不是在餐桌上进行的。它们发生在露台上。是的，尽管我一年只回去探望几次，但我仍然喜欢看风暴卷来。当雨水打在炎热的路面上时，感受到空气中温度的下降，数着雷声和闪电划过之间的时差，想知道最后那一击是否触及了地面。可能我最喜欢的部分
of all, it's still an eye where I get to sit and watch as the clouds clear and give way again to that beautiful, great fruit colored Florida sky. We have one more episode in this series celebrating 500 episodes next week. You can continue to spread the word and encourage people to listen to this or any episode of 99% Invisible, or write a review. That'd be so grateful. Thanks. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, Jason Dillion, and Kurt Colestead, mix and tech production by Martin Gonzales, original music by our director of Sound Swan Rhyang,
这一切，依然是一个露台，我坐在那里看着云开雾散，再次让那美丽、如红柚般颜色的佛罗里达天空重现。下周我们这个庆祝 500 集的系列节目还有最后一集。你可以继续传播这个消息，鼓励人们收听这一集或 99% Invisible 的任何一集，或者写一篇评论。我会非常感激的。谢谢。本周的 99% Invisible 由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、杰森·狄龙和库尔特·科尔斯特德制作，混音和技术制作由马丁·冈萨雷斯负责，原创音乐由我们的声音总监斯旺·里扬创作，
with additional music from APM, fact checking by Graham Haysha. Delaney Hall is the executive producer, Thoreso Team, is Vivian Leigh, Christopher Johnson, Chris Baroube, Losh Madon, Sophia Klatsker, Joe Rosenberg, intern Sarah Baker, and me Roman Mars. We are part of a Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful,
APM 提供额外音乐，格雷厄姆·海沙负责事实核查。德尼·霍尔是执行制片人，导演团队是维维安·李、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、克里斯·巴鲁贝、洛什·马顿、索菲亚·克拉茨克、乔·罗森伯格、实习生萨拉·贝克以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们现在是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部位于潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。位于美丽的
uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰市住宅区。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并加入关于该程序的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars，也可以在 99PI org 上@该节目。我们也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。你可以在 Facebook 上找到我喜爱的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及 99PI 的每一集过往节目。
There are 501 of them. And 99PI dot org. Do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do to do. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它们有501个。还有99PI点org。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。